welcome back to our supersize cruise
news we are joined by barbara biggs
mullen and next we're tackling some of
the latest trends and this is trending
all right first up we're talking the
latest in men's fashion i love this
story because especially when you get
the visual it really sends it over the
edge the wall street journal reports
that guys are going for kid core a trend
all about adult men dressing like tweens
that includes
anything with a youthful spirit bright
colors baggy fits and tie dyes gentlemen
please discuss
well jason we gonna see you in that
i'll tell you what i'm more a royal core
guy
when it comes to my attire in general
yeah i'm more more guilted and floral
and uh
yeah no this you will probably never see
me i mean honestly i'm i just have i'm
terrible with fashion and i uh as you
can tell and you do have a lot of
youthful clothes
you do tend to sort of
dress like oh i do tend to do like a
like a long sleeve thermal under a
t-shirt or like yeah i i do sometimes
like to dress like
jason biggs dressed in 2001 because i'll
tell you what jason biggs in 2001 killed
it
it's like little league core yeah
age man hey thank you handsome you're
very
[Applause]
developed it good
would you ever go for this trend no
i work out too much i want to like show
off my muscles you know i just like no
kids
no chances
i wouldn't wear this but i could pull it
off you know what i'm saying
at first i was like no but when i saw
this color palette i was like yes i've
got the complexion to do it and i think
we all agree and thank you so much
[Laughter]
yeah well now we've got uh the latest
beauty trend grazia reports something
called a face bra and chin masks are the
latest thing in skin care and we've got
some here to try now i will tell you i
suffer from a double chin my face is
redundant it's like chin chin
and so this look they take this
thing that has some serum in it and they
you loop it under
your neck so we have them here oh wow
this is like when you hurt your knee at
the gym they put this on you
um
you know what's interesting
i thought
that this was just going to be like why
not put my face mask down
it feels so good
it didn't feel good at first but then it
warmed up a little bit now it feels it
feels like home
refreshing
what is this supposed to do so this is
supposed to um like tighten you up down
there a little bit you're not droopy at
all but i am a member of the droopy
community i feel like i have it on the
wrong part of my body
[Laughter]
you know what i mean yours looks like
you know what i mean
tikki what is our last trend because i'm
so into our last trend finally
tick tock it's a great at showing us
some new ways to do some old things not
take care of your chin but you know what
i mean by the way tiki you have a really
strong beautiful job very so jealous
you're right and don't get me started
with you
if there's anyone i would take on a date
at this table and be you two oh thank
you you're so beautiful and by the way
that's season two for your date
it's not an old trend but people are
going bananas about this newest trend
this is something that i never would
have thought was possible but yahoo life
reports this hack comes from sydney
rashkind and it's more of a perfect way
to tie your robe watch this take it out
put it in the front
and then
it's nice
and tighter
all right okay
so it's all about in the front two from
the front
okay okay very excited to try this okay
i'm gonna be the example of how
everybody else does it right so okay
in the back it's tight you wrap it up
you're like oh this thing is still too
small
you wrap it up
and you go for a walk and it's like oh
my god i'm exposed
flirting again
[Applause]
um
it's
so much better this is so much so much
better and way more flattering is it
cuter totally yes because i i don't like
that digging in feel and you're right
like my
my junk is not about to pop out like
i i am really into that wow i'm
impressed that's correct what do you
think would you where is he all would
you wear this yeah i'm gonna do this
next time i
wear a robe i have to say i some of
these attacks and tips and tricks i'm
like i don't know and then some you're
like whoa yeah yeah this one i am here
for this
how did we not figure this out
i don't know thank you tick tock thank
you changed our lives well
as usual and having done this show with
you guys multiple times
i just want to keep doing this i love
being with you guys this is so much fun
these are just special days they're
light they're fun they're interesting
and they just make life better so please
can we do this again
[Applause]
thank you barbara catch him on tiki and
tyranny on wsa sports radio and always
jason fakes with jenny mullins jenny's
debut novel city of lights is out june
14th we are all here for it and we'll be
right back
[Music]